marina de guerra del perú confirmó el
segundo derrame de petróleo en el mismo
lugar el desastre ecológico ocurrido el
15 de enero esta vez se calcula que
fueron 8 barriles de hidrocarburo que
fueron vertidos al mar cuando la
transnacional repsol realizaba tareas de
inspección de una tubería ante el
imprevisto desplegó barreras de
contención la marina de guerra y el
ejército han movilizado a brigadas
multipropósito para apoyar la limpieza
de playas afectadas por el derrame de
6.000 barriles de crudo producido hace
más de 10 días diversos expertos
advierten que el petróleo del primer
derrame dejará graves daños en el
ecosistema por décadas al respecto la
procuraduría especializada en
medioambiente señaló que existen cuatro
funcionarios de repsol que enfrentan
hasta siete años de prisión por la
presunta comisión del delito de
contaminación agravada el desastre
ecológico afecta a la flora fauna y
también la economía de pescadores
artesanales a través de redes sociales
diversos colectivos civiles convocan la
población a una jornada de protesta el
próximo 31 de enero para exigir al
gobierno del presidente pedro casi el
cese de operaciones de repsol